deutschland hat corona bisher besser
überstanden als viele andere länder auf
der welt
warum ich glaube vor allem weil wir so
sind wie wir sind
wir halten uns gerne an regeln in
deutschland wir melden gern die die sich
nicht an die regeln halten wir stecken
unsere eltern und großeltern nicht an
weil wir sie nur selten sehen und schon
gar nicht mit ihnen wohnen anders als
zum beispiel im süden europas
wir können es uns leisten monatelang auf
kurzarbeit zu hause zu sitzen weil wir
dafür seit jahren sehr viel gearbeitet
haben sehr viel hergestellt sehr viel in
alle welt verkauft und sehr viel steuern
bezahlt haben
wir haben ein gesundheitssystem gebaut
in dem nordrhein westfalen mehr
beatmungs betten hat als ganz italien
wir könnten alle dankbar sein für die
möglichkeiten die wir hatten ein so
krisenfestes robustes land geschaffen zu
haben
stattdessen aber die spaltung und wut
radikalisierung und gereiztheit
gleichzeitig überhebliche und
gefährlichen selbstzufriedenheit
meine beobachtung der vergangenen woche
auf einer der sonnigsten demos der
deutschen geschichte wehen in berlin
regenbogen fahren neben der bei neonazis
beliebten fahne des kaiserreichs schwarz
weiß rot die farben auch die farben der
nazis grüne studienräte marschieren dort
neben hakenkreuz tattoos friedensbewegte
und profisportler mit dunkler hautfarbe
in rufweite von rechtsextremen menschen
ohne maske demonstrieren gegen eine
masken diktatur die sie freundlich gegen
jede regel verstossen lässt während die
polizei auf twitter behauptet man dulde
keine regelverstöße gleichzeitig toben
auf twitter die bewahrer der einzig
wahren haltung die vor wenigen tagen
noch ohne maske mit tausenden in
berliner parks feierten und wo wenigen
wochen noch ohne maske zu zehntausenden
für blackwater demonstrierten über die
kurve die otn was rücksichtslos ist
hängt plötzlich von der gesinnung ab
apropos rücksichtslos journalisten und
talkshows erste fordern auf twitter dass
man nun personalien der demonstranten
aufnehmen solle
um ihnen eine behandlung ein
beatmungsgerät zu verweigern
sie sterben zu lassen sollten sie an
corona erkannten herzchen und likes für
die idee im krankenhaus nach politischer
gesinnung zu selektieren
so weit sind wir gekommen menschen die
eben noch gegen polizeigewalt
demonstrierten fordern nun den einsatz
von wasserwerfern auf beiden seiten des
irrsinns habe ich das gefühl man sehnte
sich steigende infektionszahlen nach
black leisten
demos oder der berliner kundgebung vom
wochenende geradezu herbei nur um zu
belegen dass die andere seite tod und
verderben bringt und sie dann mit
unerbittlicher härte zu verfolgen
das geschrei dass wir derzeit erleben
ist nicht der schräge schrille klang der
meinungsfreiheit nein es ist das
schnarren dass die meinung der anderen
tilgen will
was mich besonders sorgt das politische
klima wird immer irrationaler
irrsinniger und feindseliger und das
obwohl sommerferien sind das wetter
schön ist und millionen menschen fast
voll bezahlt frei haben
aber man spürt bei vielen bereits die
sorge und die gereiztheit der
aufziehenden rezession
es wird ein langer winter der wahrheit
werden der waren pleiten und der waren
arbeitslosenzahlen wenn erster politiker
wie etwa markus söder jetzt vorschlagen
das kurzarbeitergeld zitat bis weit ins
nächste jahr zu verlängern dann lautet
die übersetzung der staat
beziehungsweise der steuerzahler zahlen
die gehälter bis der wahlkampf 2021 so
gut wie ausgestanden ist
denn seeland im arbeitsmarkt laut
millionenfach die radikalisierung die
wir am wochenende auf der straße und in
den sozialen medien erleben konnten
es wird einen großen unterschied machen
ob die menschen mit oder eben ohne
arbeit auf die infektionszahlen blicken
wir die gereizten jetzt als die neuen
besorgten abtut wird sie verlieren oder
mit kurzarbeitergeld kaufen müssen
wenn auf demos regenbogenfahnen und
schwarz weiß rot nebeneinander wehen
dann sollten wir kennen corona ist für
die politik genauso unberechenbar und
gefährlich wie für unsere gesundheit